[Music]
the coronavirus pandemic
which has claimed so many lives around
the world
has caused unprecedented economic damage
too
rapid and colossal support from
governments and the eu
has helped to cash in some of the
impacts
and growth has been recovering but
uncertainty is still high
overall the european economy like the
global economy
is forecast to contract significantly
this year
before bouncing back over the course of
2021 and 2022
the recovery like the recession was
is expected to be uneven with some
countries and sectors set to benefit
more than
others financial support from the
governments and the eu
has been vital for businesses and
citizens this year
and will play a defining role in the
recovery
public deficits are therefore expected
to be
significantly higher than in recent
years
for as long as such exceptional support
is needed
the same is true for public debt which
is forecast to rise
markedly this year government
programs and eu initiatives such as sure
have helped to limit job losses in
europe
but some increase in unemployment will
be inevitable
inflation by contrast should fall this
year
due to the economic contraction and the
drop in
oil prices we are living so in
exceptional times
europe's economic outlook depends
heavily
on the evolution of the pandemic and
other factors
such as developments in international
trade
and the global economy the crisis
has shown that europe is capable of
powerful policy
responses that can make a huge
meaningful difference to our citizens
lives
the 750 billion euro next
generation eu program will have a
sizable positive
impact in all our member states and will
help
prepare europe for a more prosperous
fairer
green and digital future